[Musique]
les casques blancs en séries ont été mis
sur pied officiellement en 2013 pour
venir en aide aux victimes de la guerre
en syrie aussi connue comme la défense
civile syrienne cette organisation
humanitaire a été financé par les etats
unis le royaume uni la france
l'allemagne le danemark les pays bas le
canada et le japon
inspiré des casques blancs de l'onu
créée en 1995 pour appuyer l'aide
humanitaire d'urgence des nations unies
la défense civile syrienne a regroupé
des centaines de bénévoles qui
intervenait spontanément dans leur ville
et dans leurs villages pour répondre aux
urgences humanitaires et aux nécessités
matérielles imposées par le conflit ils
ont été jusqu'à 4000 ans tous présents
essentiellement dans les zones
contrôlées par l'opposition
donc priver des services de l'état est
ciblé par les forces de bachar al assad
plusieurs ont été tués et d'autres ont
fui le pays
on ne sait plus combien ils sont encore
sur le terrain et leur vie est menacée
par le régime syrien
[Musique]